bon ça je dois juste vous dire pour
commencer peut-être là rien n'était
impossible à celui qui croit je crois
que j'en suis une démonstration vivante
je pense que toute épreuve peut être
surmonté à partir du moment où il ya un
regard d'espérance quelque chose qui
nous permet justement de croire avoir
confiance quelque chose qui va faire
grandir peut-être au dedans nous
simplement un peu de résilience bien sûr
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à comprendre
ça j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à
apprendre conscience qu'il y avait
quelque chose de lumineux en moi j'ai
grandi dans des idées xviiie
arrondissement et c'est vrai que ma vie
a été brisée et un peu au départ
pourtant la belle histoire a commencé en
amont étaient mes 14 ans alors j'étais
déjà dans consommateurs de cannabis
c'est assez avancé mais là je me suis
vraiment fait voler mon âme par une
courtisane je l'appellerai tout
simplement l'héroïne
donc ça avait bien commencé parce que
les éducateurs spécialisés de rue
avaient conduit les petits des cités en
vacances dans le sud de la france à
antibes et là j'ai fait cette expérience
qui a été mon premier face à face à avec
l'héroïne et samaa ça m'a brûlée à peu
près quinze ans de ma vie
quinze ans où j'ai vécu ce qu'on
appellerait l'enfer des drogues donc
malheureusement j'ai fait pas tout seul
dans cette histoire puisque après
quelques années j'ai fait cette
expérience enfin cette expérience j'ai
rencontré ma compagne est tous les deux
on a commencé à tomber a sombré dans
l'héroïne
ça a été compliqué ça a été vraiment
compliqué puisque même quand on a essayé
d'arrêter à ses 20 ans à peu près voilà
elle est tombée enceinte quatrième mois
de grossesse on lui a annoncé qu'elle
avait le sida et le jour où on lui a
fait une interruption de grossesse je
crois que tous les deux on a vrillé tous
les deux on s'est laissé emporter dans
des choix de mort je fait plusieurs
tentatives de suicide par overdose les
pompiers et paris m'ont sauvé la vie et
je me suis retrouvé à fresnes accusé
d'un homicide volontaire un règlement
qui s'était mal passé enfin avec le
monde compte qui s'était mal passé
j'essaie juste l'été défendre un de mes
potes sur un trafic et il ya une
trentaine d'années de ça et donc dans
cette prison on m'a annoncé que j'avais
la maladie du sida
et autant vous dire que pour moi voilà
je pense que l'espérance de vie était
plutôt de zéro alors j'ai laissé mes
pensées être envahis de penser mans et
là aussi j'ai préparé mon suicide
je me suis fabriqué une lame j'ai
attendu que les détenus sont dorment et
en plein milieu de la nuit face à ma
propre roman je dirais je crois que j'ai
fait de ce face-à-face ultime est
quelque chose qui ressemblerait
peut-être une révélation
j'ai crié j'ai pleuré et à cet instant
j'ai ressenti comme une paix comme une
présence quelque chose que j'avais
jamais l'habitude d'avoir
et en fait c'est cette paix c'était
comme une lumière quoi je sais pas
comment expliquer c'est toujours
difficile à expliquer mais à partir de
ce moment là j'ai commencé à découvrir
que il y avait peut-être quelque chose
dedans de moi
il est peut-être quelque chose qui
pouvait justement me permettre de me
battre alors j'ai lâché la lame et je me
suis battu contre tous mes petits démons
et d'ailleurs la justice des hommes a
reconnu légitime défense
j'ai sorti avec un non-lieu à l'histoire
pourrait s'arrêter là simplement
malheureusement encore une fois dans ses
côtés on peut dire ténébreux de ma vie
je me laissais encore emporté je me suis
laissé encore malheureusement tenté et
les choses ne sont
on pas arrangé puisque ma compagne est
tombé gravement malade du sida
elle est morte quelques années après et
moi je sais c'était vraiment mal j'étais
vraiment très très mal alors j'ai essayé
de donner un sens à tout ça je cherchais
alors j'allais dans les endroits où kiki
qui pouvaient m'inspirer on va dire ça
comme ça et je regardais un personnage
qui qui mêlait parce que je me disais de
la houle est peut-être que il peut
comprendre ma souffrance et en même
temps j'avais cette sensation ou oui
cette sensation cette tentation de
croire que même lui m'avait abandonné
enfin voilà ce que ce que j'avais mis ma
foi en prison voilà tout partait en
vrille et j'ai basculé dans la folie
on m'a enfermée dans voilà dans un enfin
un hôpital psychiatrique secteur 2
secteur 2 ça veut dire secteur fermé pas
le droit de visite pas loire de de
sortir alors quand j'étais en prison
quand j'allais au juge je passais
j'avais les entraves au pied aux mains
mais j'étais debout
hinges été tirée par enfin pied et un
gendarme qui me tenait mais là j'étais
attaché au lit j'avais un libre j'avais
une chambre pour moi tout seul s'est
attaché au lit et c'était terrible parce
que alors c'était pas des mots
l'intensité c'était vraiment d'aider des
liens et si on n'est pas fait pour vivre
comme des esclaves quoi s était c'était
encore pire que la prison je dirai pas
ce que j'ai même plus la notion de
penser alors ils ont été sympas quand
même ils m'ont attaché différemment et
m'ont donné ce qu'on appelle la camisole
chimique
donc j'avais 29 ans en gros et je fais
incapable de manger tout seul
ces traitements mon shoot est
complètement c'était pas le d'héroïne
c'était vraiment un produit
prenez ma tension toutes les deux heures
et on me donnait à manger à la petite
cuillère excusez moi pour les détails
mais voilà faut savoir d'où on peut
venir aussi
on me torcher à 29 ans j'étais incapable
voilà de faire quoi que ce soit on me
positionner devant une devant une
télévision qui passaient en boucle et je
devenais fou quand j'avais l'impression
que la télé mans elle-même m'insultait
j'avais juste envie de la casser et puis
le sida s'est déclarée donc une maladie
opportuniste
le x 2 x fibrose et à cause de la drogue
l'alcool et est donc j'ai été dans un
service de ce qu'on appelle des sidéens
à l'époque il y avait aucun traitement
dans ce service était dans le xviiie
arrondissement et à bichat et là j'avais
l'impression que voilà même voilà le
face à face face à ma mort et encore une
fois je me rappelais de ce que j'avais
vécu en prison et je voulais simplement
brics concilier me réconcilier pour
mourir en paix alors me réconcilier avec
ma famille parce que j'étais vraiment
loin de détromper avec eux puisque je
fais pas mal de conneries je l'aurais
brisé la vie est un homme est venu la
rencontre avec une personne qui pour moi
est un symptôme
ouais ils avaient toutes les
applications en lui encore une fois la
paix la joie l'amour est des choses qui
peut te permettre justement de la tlv de
faire quelque chose comme ça c'est la
première personne qui m'a dit alors que
j'avais 29 ans j'étais quelqu'un de bien
en fait
et ça on ne l'avait jamais dit et c'est
incroyable parce que j'y croyais pas je
pouvais pas comprendre ce qui me disait
et puis voilà je sais pas il ya eu
quelque chose dedans de moi qui m'a
permis de croire que peut-être cet homme
avait raison peut-être que au dedans de
moi effectivement un y avait peut-être
quelque chose de lumineux alors j'ai
écouté ses conseils cet homme là m'a
conduit dans une communauté religieuse
qui accueillait des malades fin de vie
cancer en phase terminale sida ce
terminal et je suis arrivé dans cet
endroit pour y mourir en fait et suave
de culture je suis tombé sur des hommes
et des femmes consacrées à dieu et je
suis resté neuf ans et là le miracle a
commencé puisque pendant trois ans les
médecins m'ont dit que voilà je je je
devais pas vive et comme quoi rien
n'était impossible à celui qui croit ma
compagne n'a pas eu la même chance que
moi les mortes à 25 ans et c'est vrai
que quand on a trouvé des traitements
contre le vih
là aussi encore une fois quelque chose
qui m'a permis de d'avancé il ya quelque
chose qui m'a permis de me projeter il
ya quelque chose qui m'a permis
justement de donner un sens trouver ma
place ici m'a donné un but en fait
et je pensais que c'était dans le monde
religieux puis le bon dieu m'a montré
que on n'était pas obligé d'être
religieux pour être rendus capables
d'aimer et d'être aimé et de donner
envie d'aimer peut-être et elle m'a
permis de rencontrer une femme donc un
face à face face à l'amour ils ne
rencontraient un incroyable puisque
c'était encore une fois humainement
impossible je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure il y en est impossible à celui
qui croit alors on s'est marié ce va
faire 20 ans qu'on est marié
on a quitté cette communauté à la
naissance enfin ou un an de ma fille
donc là aussi les médecins m'ont dit je
ne pourrais pas avoir d'enfant donc j'ai
deux super enfants qui sont en bonne
santé et c'est vrai qu'à la naissance de
ma fille ben ouais quelque chose qui qui
est à quai qui maintient qui va impacter
1 comme quoi on est on
je crois que la vie bien plus fort que
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut avoir vécu
dans notre histoire
donc j'ai quitté cette communauté et
voilà mes enfants donc ma fille à 18 ans
elle aussi ait fait une fac de droit
moi qui ait jamais été à l'école bon
c'est quand même juste incroyable mon
garçon il est encore au collège et je
crois que aucune prétention je crois que
j'ai j'ai pu justement réussir à
construire quelque chose réussir à
réussir tout simplement ma vie puisque
aujourd'hui je n'ai jamais été autant à
l'école que ces dernières années puisque
au travers de mon témoignage je fais
dans les établissements scolaires leur
parler de ce message comme quoi
justement rien qui est impossible à
celui qui croit voilà merci
[Applaudissements]